Idea of individual responsibility
through through 12 rules,
while we might say we might begin by
thinking about how that's related to the
idea of free speech.
It's like
you have to find your way in the world,
let's say with all of your
peculiarities,
your idiosyncrasies and your differences
and the way you do that is by acting in
the world,
but the way you prepare to act is by
thinking and really what you're doing
when you're thinking.
There's a philosopher named Alfred North
Whitehead who said something very
intelligent about thinking.
He said that the reason we think is so
that our thoughts can die instead of us.
Right?
And it's a Darwinian idea.
So the way animals adapt to the world
across time is that animals produced
variance very into offspring.
Many of them,
and most of them were unsuccessful and
die,
but a few of them are successful enough
in that time and place to reproduce.
And so the animal keeps living across
the millennia varying slightly as it
does.
So to adapt to the transformations of
the environment.
Human beings do the same thing,
but we also have figured out how to
abstract that and so what we do when we
think is that we produce a fictional
world that's a simulation of the real
world and we populate that simulated
world with simulations of us and then we
let those simulations play out in the
simulated world and the ones that are
successful,
we embody and act out and the ones that
are unsuccessful.
We abandoned and let die and we do that.
When we're thinking in dreams and we do
that when we think in stories and we
even do that when we think in words.
Although it's not as obvious when you
argue internally,
which is what you do when you think you
have an Avatar that manifests itself as
one point of view and an Avatar that
manifests itself as another and you let
them engage in conflict and the one that
loses you let go off.
That's a sacrifice and if you're
discussing something with someone and
it's important that you both put your
viewpoints forward and you analyze the
consequences of the dispute and then you
walk away with any luck,
why is there then you were so that you
can embody a motive being that's more
likely to be successful and you do that
in part in large part by exercising your
freedom of speech and you might think,
well,
why?
Freedom of speech and freedom of
thought,
and the answer to that is don't be
thinking that you think because thinking
is very hard and most people can't think
at all and even if you can think you're
not very good at it.
I mean think about what you have to do
technically to think.
First of all,
you have to formulate the problem that's
hard enough and you have to formulate it
precisely.
Then have to generate multiple potential
solutions to the problem and then you
have to let those solutions argue
themselves into a hierarchy internally
and so you have to be able to tolerate
that stress,
right?
You can't just be one thing if you're
going to think because thinking isn't
just saying that.
What I think is right,
that's not thinking at all.
Thinking is questioning whether or not
what you think is right is right and
that's really hard.
It's very demanding and so and you can
do that to some degree,
but you're not as good at it as you
think.
Even if you're a pretty good thinker.
Mostly the way you think is by talking
and you talk and mostly when you talk
and think it's contentious as you know
if you've ever had an intimate
relationship with someone because an
intimate relationship,
if it,
if it has any worth at all,
is a place where there's tremendous
contention but it's bounded within
something approximating mutual respect
and the willingness to continue to play
the game across time and the reason that
an intimate relationship is contentious
because life is very,
very difficult and people are different
and we face extraordinarily complex
problems together.
Like how to make a living and how to.
How to operate properly in our careers
and how to rank order the importance of
our careers and how to manage our
domestic economies and how to discipline
our kids and whether or not to have kids
and how to enter middle age and how to
grow old gracefully and how to live
productively and where to vacation and
all of these things which are
extraordinarily difficult problems and
the only way that we can solve them is
by butting heads to some degree and
communicating freely about what the
possibilities are and negotiating a
solution and that's thinking and in
order to do that thinking,
you have to be able to speak freely and
you certainly have to be willing to
offend someone.
I mean,
of all the stupid questions I've ever
been asked by journalists,
the question,
what makes you think you have the right
to offend someone by what you say is by
far the most miraculously ignorant and I
say that because,
well,
no,
it just.
It just sets me back on my heels to some
degree because I think,
well,
what's your claim here?
Your claim is.
Your first claim is we could
hypothetically discussed something
important without one of us getting
upset.
It's like,
that's not gonna happen.
If you ever discuss anything important
with anyone,
including just discussing it with
yourself,
not only are you going to get upset,
you're going to get so upset that you
probably won't even do it.
You know,
you think,
well,
I have a difficult problem.
What do you.
What's your first reaction?
Well,
I'm going to sit right here and think
about that.
It's like,
no,
that isn't your reaction.
Your reaction is to go like play a video
game or watch a youtube video or or
vacuum your bedroom or do the dishes or
whatever can do not to think about that.
That's what you're going to do.
So you know,
and then if you're going to have a
discussion with your wife or your
husband or your kids and it's about
something important.
It's like if you're a normal person,
your heart rate goes up and it's like
it's demanding and then you have to
think it through and then you're
probably wrong and you're going to
stumble over your words and God only
knows if you're going to reach a
solution and you can't tell if it's
going to mean the end of your damn
relationship and like the catastrophe
lurks everywhere when you're discussing
difficult issues and the rule is
something like,
but you can't offend anyone.
It's like,
well then okay,
fine.
Then you never get to talk about
anything that's important with anyone
ever including yourself.
So like that's supposed to be the rule.
Then you think,
well even if it's not quite that bad,
it's like let's say,
so here I'm addressing about 850 people,
something like that.
It's like,
what's the probability that I could talk
about anything that any of you would
ever want to listen to for more than
about 15 seconds,
you know,
that would grip your interest without me
or offending at least one person in this
room with each sentence.
There's a thousand people in here,
you know,
and some people are unbelievably easy to
offend.
There's that.
They're just looking for a reason to be
offended,
so,
so there's that problem.
But if we're going to deal with things
that are,
that are solid and contentious and why,
talk about things that we already all
agree on.
We've already solved those problems.
We can only really talk about things we
don't agree on.
It's the only thing worth talking about.
Well,
of course everyone's going to be
offended.
And so for a journalist to ask that,
it's like,
what the Hell's with you?
What?
What planet do you inhabit?
Don't you understand that your entire
discipline is predicated on not only
your right to offend someone,
but the responsibility that you have to
offend people.
It's like that's it's
cool thinking isn't offensive act,
which is why tyrants hated,
right?
Because one of the rules and tyranny is
don't think why?
Because I already know all the answers
and you're supposed to accept my answers
as the tyrant and so there's no need for
your thinking.
And you might be saying,
well,
my life isn't going as well as it could,
and the tyrant says,
well,
you don't get to think that because in
my utopian tyranny,
everything's perfect.
And if you're suffering,
that means you're politically suspect
because you're suffering.
Your inability to recognize that the
utopia has already manifested itself.
Your unhappiness is actually a political
crime,
but if you just keep it to yourself,
well we'll let you keep your head,
but you have the the.
If you're driven to the extreme where
you have to express the fact that you're
unhappy,
perhaps that your child doesn't have
enough to eat,
then it's off to the Gulag with you and
all your family as well because there'll
be no thinking here and even if there
is,
they'll certainly be no talking.
Here's something that happened recently
in Venezuela,
Mrs. Worth Thinking about for all the
people who harbor collectivist Utopian
Dreams,
Venezuela,
the Venezuelan government about two
months ago,
this was reported in the New York Times,
which is not a newspaper.
I would say that would be intrinsically
biased against Venezuela.
Said that it was now illegal to diagnose
the cause of a child's death in a
Venezuelan hospital as starvation
because the Venezuelans,
Venezuelan government's answer to the
problem of children starving was to make
it illegal to notice it in hospitals.
And that's a tyranny,
right?
That's a place where thought is not
allowed.
That's a place where free speech is not
So it seems to me that that's not a good
place to go to say the least.
And we've gone there many times in the
last one,
hundred and 50 years and we should
perhaps think very hard about whether or
not we ever want to go there again.